NEED THIS BED.
>> Tucker: THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS SAID TO SHUT DOWN
FRIDAY OF THIS WEEK UNLESS
CONGRESS CAN PASS A SPENDING
BILL.
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS SEEM
LIKE THEY'RE ABOUT TO DO THAT.
THEY SAY THEY ARE, SO WHAT'S IN
THE DEAL?
PROBABLY NOT A LOT OF WHAT YOU
VOTED FOR IN 2016 PER THE FINAL
BILL IS EXPECTED TO SPEND
$1.3 TRILLION, THAT WILL
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE
DEFICIT.
WHEN IT WON'T DO IS PROVIDE A
SINGLE DOLLAR FOR THE BORDER
WALL, EVEN THOUGH THE PRESIDENT
GOT ELECTED, AS YOU MAY
REMEMBER, ON A PLEDGE TO BUILD
ONE.
THAT WILL NOT PULL FUNDING FROM
CENTURY CITIES EVEN THOUGH THOSE
SAID WILL USE OUR ACTING TO
SABOTAGE, EVEN ON A SPENDING
BILL WOULD CONTINUE TO GIVE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF TAX
DOLLARS TO PLANNED PARENTHOOD
WHOSE DIRECTOR SPOKE AT THE
DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION.
MEANWHILE, THE PRIORITIES OF
THIS CONGRESS SEEM TO BE MET BY
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY RATHER THAN
A PARTY SUPPOSEDLY IN CHARGE.
DEMOCRATS DEFINE THE IMMIGRATION
DEBATE SINCE DAY ONE, AND OTHER
DURING THE CEMENT GUN CONTROL.
HOW SHOULD REPUBLICAN VOTERS
FEEL ABOUT ALL OF THIS?
BRIT HUME HAS WATCHED A LOT OF
THIS.
IS THERE A CONCERN THAT
REPUBLICAN VOTERS WILL LOOK AT
THIS AND BE DISAPPOINTED OR WILL
THEY BE SO AFRAID OF DEMOCRATS
THAT THEY'LL BE MOTIVATED TO
VOTE ANYWAY?
>> I'M NOT SURE THAT'S QUITE THE
CHOICE.
I'M SURE REPUBLICAN VOTERS WILL
BE DISAPPOINTED WITH THIS, BUT
THIS IS A VERY FAMILIAR PATTERN
WE ARE SEEING AND IT COMES DOWN
TO THIS, IT'S A QUESTION OF
NARROW MAJORITIES.
THE UNITED STATES SENATE TODAY,
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS THE
NARROWEST OF MAJORITIES AND ON
MOST LEGISLATIVE MEASURES, IT
TAKES 60 VOTES, THAT MEANS YOU
NEED DEMOCRATS.
DEMOCRATS WHEN IT COMES TO A BIG
MEASURE LIKE THIS, ARE GOING TO
STAND BY THEIR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, BILL TRY THEIR BEST
TO GET THE DACA MEASURE RENEWED,
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET THAT BY
THE WAY IN THIS BILL, BUT THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT GOING TO GET
HIS BORDER WALL FUNDING EITHER,
SO THERE YOU GO.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WITH A
NARROW MAJORITY.
IF THE REPUBLICANS HAD HEALTHY
MAJORITIES IN BOTH HOUSES, THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO PASS A BILL
THAT WOULD CONTAIN ALL THE
PRIORITIES YOU CITED AND OTHERS
AS WELL AND THE DEMOCRATS
COULDN'T DO A THING ABOUT IT.
UNDER THESE CIRCUMSTANCES, THEY
CAN'T DO THAT BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE VOTES.
>> Tucker: IT'S CLEAR THEY
CAN'T, BUT I WONDER GOING INTO
IT IF THERE WASN'T OVERPROMISING
IT IF THERE WASN'T OVERPROMISIN
OVERPROMISING.
IF PEOPLE'S EXPECTATIONS AREN'T
MET, IF SOMEONE SAYS THEY'LL BUY
YOU A PONY FOR CHRISTMAS AND NEW
GET A BAG OF HAIR, WHY CAN'T
THEY DELIVER?
>> ON THE COURSE OF AN ELECTION
CAMPAIGN, YOU DON'T KNOW HOW THE
ELECTION WILL TURN OUT, YOU COME
OUT AND YOU SAY THIS IS WHAT I'M
FOR, THIS IS WHAT I'M GOING TO
BE TRYING TO DO.
OF COURSE THAT GETS TRANSLATED
TO THIS IS WHAT I WILL DO.
BELIEVE ME, THERE ARE DEMOCRATIC
REPRESENTATIVES AND SENATORS ALL
OVER THIS COUNTRY WHO WENT OUT
AND PROMISED ALL KINDS OF THINGS
THAT THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET
EITHER.
THAT'S HOW IT IS ONE GOVERNMENT
IS DIVIDED LIKE THIS, VERY
NARROWLY AND IT'S NOT A PRETTY
SIGHT.
IT USED TO BE BACK IN THE DAY,
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME SINCE I'VE
SEEN IT WORK THIS WAY WHEN THERE
WOULD BE A SERIES OF FUNDING
BILLS THAT WOULD BE DEBATED AND
VOTED ON AND THEN THE TWO HOUSES
WOULD GET TOGETHER AND THEY
WOULD TRY TO RESOLVE THEIR
DIFFERENCES AND THERE WAS A LOT
OF BIPARTISAN SENTIMENT AND
EVERYDAY WOULD GIVE A LITTLE TO
GET A LITTLE.
IN THIS DIVIDED ATMOSPHERE,
CONGRESS IS A REFLECTION OF THE
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE A VERY DEEPLY DIVIDED
NATION AND THE GRIDLOCK THAT
YOU'RE SEEING THE LEAST OF THIS
KIND OF EXTRAVAGANZA,
$1.3 TRILLION AS A RESULT OF
THAT.
>> Tucker: YOU SAID DEMOCRATS
STAND BY THEIR SACRED COWS, WHAT
ARE THOSE?
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY WON'T
COMPROMISE ON?
>> ONE THING IS A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN DEFENSE SPENDING
WHICH THEY WANTED FOR A LONG
TIME.
THEY HAD TO SWALLOW SOME
INCREASES IN DOMESTIC SPENDING
THEY MAY NOT HAVE WANTED, BUT
THEY'RE GOING TO GET THAT AND
OBVIOUSLY, THEY GOT THEIR TAX
BILL PASSED AND THAT WILL LEAVE
UNDER
UNDISTURBED.
ONE OF THE GREAT PRIORITIES THAT
HAS DEFINED THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
GOING BACK A NUMBER OF CYCLES
HAS BEEN THE DESIRE TO GET INTO
THE ENTITLEMENT SPENDING AND
REDUCE THAT BECAUSE THAT IS A
BIG DRIVER OF THESE STAGGERING
DEFICITS IN THE NATIONAL DEBT
THAT WE NOW FACE.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT NOW WHO IS
NOT FOR THAT.
WITHOUT THAT, YOU HAVE NO
MOMENTUM BEHIND THAT.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF REPUBLICAN
PRIORITIES ON THIS BILL, NO
DOUBT ABOUT IT.
I CAN'T ENUMERATE THEM ALL, BUT
ANYTHING THIS BIG, THEY'RE BOUND
TO BE.
REMEMBER THIS ABOUT THIS BILL,
IT'S SUBJECT TO THE SAME THING
BUILD BILLS ALWAYS ARE.
BIG BILLS HAVE TO PAY.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO TRY TO
ATTACH WHATEVER THEY'VE GOT TO
THAT BILL BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT'S
GOING TO GET PAST.
YOU GET ALL KINDS OF UGLY
ORNAMENTS HANGING ONTO THESE
THINGS.
A LOT OF THEM GET STRIPPED OUT,
BUT A LOT GET THROUGH.